today I'll stick to football the band is
back together baby all three of us fresh
off of influenza we are back unlike our
Texas Longhorns but we have some college
football awards to hand out we're gonna
play top five what-ifs
it's me a fun one what ifs what if we'd
hired page instead of Melo we don't
never know so happens what here's a fun
one not on the rundown
what if dead Dan had lived it would this
be a four person show no I don't think
you would me start you guys would Silva
bartender that'd be good
there won't be nice on YouTube there
would just be a long awkward call yes
with a beer okay let's go around the
league Melo Connor welcome to the show
watch it on YouTube next week by the way
we are off YouTube the next two weeks
because the holiday so just listen to
the show while you're driving working
out ignoring your family or Christmas
whatever it is three shows next week
like always let's start the show right
here though guys Jordan love declared
for the draft accepted his invite to the
Senior Bowl a big week and promptly got
arrested in cited for marijuana
possession I don't really care about
that I mean I think we'll see the NFL go
the way of major league baseball and
eventually not test for this anymore but
here's the crazy part of this story
the police were called guys because some
students in the apartment complex
smelled weed and complained so they
called the cops what a bunch of narc
yeah what the biggest nerds in the world
2020 a month yeah it's a bit ridiculous
now I will say we've us three talked
about this in our group texts that we
don't care that it was weed and we think
it's ridiculous that somebody ratted on
them it is poor awareness I think it is
love this is not the time for you to get
in any kind of trouble after such a big
week whether it was the declaration
whether it is the Senior Bowl plenty of
round one
talk but at the end of the day I think
this is something that will will breeze
by us pretty quickly like a puff of
smoke like yeah just up and his lawyer
did come out and say that he they expect
the charges to be dropped I it's just
we're talking about it because the draft
prospect and he got cited so we have to
talk about it but yeah it does suck that
he got cited I don't know that it's
gonna affect his draft stock at all I
think a lot of NFL teams will just yeah
you know what don't get caught in the
NFL we know people do it don't get
caught don't make it a problem they're
going to drug test you on April 20th if
you pass that test you're not gonna get
tested again for a year so there you go
I can't believe that people in the NFL
get drug tested more than I do
I'm a teacher Ivan yeah I've been drug
tested in a long time
neither not that I'm aware of anyway Oh
brag I would pass them oh yeah I'd be
good all right KJ Costello not going to
the NFL he's going to transfer 13
Stanford players guys have entered the
transfer portal since the season ended I
don't know what's going on with coach
Shaw there you don't normally see this
from such a stable program but KJ
Costello starting quarterback at times I
mean he wasn't the starter when we were
there to watch them play at times this
year he's gonna transfer I don't know if
you don't remember this last summer
there was a little bit of Draft hype I
think it was mostly ESPN manufacturer
but there was some draft hype about KJ
Costello I personally never understood
it never saw it I thought he would have
been a late round pick but I think as a
college quarterback this to me is about
at the level of Kelly Bryant
transferring it doesn't really resonate
but it's a name a starter from a big
program it's gonna be leaving we kind of
have to cover it I don't know if I mean
if he goes to a Texas Tech maybe it
resonates a little bit but it doesn't I
don't think this is a guy that's gonna
go to Oklahoma put Spencer rattler on
the bench right right I don't think so
either I said probably Washington State
is where this guy ends up I go there
like the secondary transfer you four
quarterbacks go see what you can do up
there you're still in the pac-12 you're
staying in the north you're gonna be
with that friendly offense it seems like
a good fit that this is alarming that
there are 13 players from Stanford in
the transfer portal right now six of
them are from
offensive or defensive line this is a
program that usually just turns out
talent after talent there to see these
guys leave I think a coach like David
Shaw might have to give a little bit
more attention to these NFL teams that
are coming after him because they're
still gonna probably call we've been
talking about him for a very long time
as being an NFL kind of guy if you're
losing 13 players off this roster that's
gonna be tough maybe there's something
to it it's something to keep an eye on
at least yeah it definitely is I mean
when you look at it this is a program
that often has a reputation for actually
keeping players at school a lot of guys
from Stanford go back for their senior
year a lot of four-year starters or at
least four-year players when you look at
castelo really good 2018 season he was
completing over 65 percent of his passes
29 touchdowns 11 picks he was hurt this
year but when he played he also wasn't
very good just not a very good season
and as matt said somebody that projected
to be at a three quarterback prospects
so he's gonna hopefully find the right
program that rebuilds that stock to
making him a draftable player again
after one more college season yeah and
he was actually someone I was wondering
if he would be a senior book guy mm-hmm
but but no now transfers and that's not
on the rundown but I do want to mention
that Shea Patterson Stephen Montez
Jordan Love and Anthony Gordon are are
for right now senior ball quarterbacks
guys there's room for eight I think six
is probably the ideal number but they've
been carrying about eight I tells you
all you need to know yeah they're
waiting just to make some decisions but
who would it be I mean it's Hertz burro
and Herbert I don't know who the fourth
one would be Nate Stanley on there no
he's not and he should be that's a big
one I think they're probably waiting for
Ethan then because he is so probably one
of those who graduate trying to figure
out is he gonna declare is he eligible
but this was his fourth year in school
he should have graduated no judgment no
judgment I didn't graduate in four years
what people do it I think the question
is gonna be if LSU wins a national title
or just makes it which they should yep
that's a law
season four jobber oh I actually wrote
about that it comes out as people you
can go read it right now Scottie
notebook it's a one week because the
title games of the 13th you report to
the Senior Bowl the 20th mhm so you get
six days basically off before you have
to be in mobile we saw Baker Mayfield
though and I think that without it he's
not the first pick in the draft I think
going to the Senior Bowl proven his
leadership in the way that he threw the
ball there now he looked very impressive
all week I do think that really helped
him I think Joe burrow is in a similar
situation but man he is head and
shoulders above some of these other
quarterbacks I guess they maybe you go I
think if the Bengals are the coaching
staff that are there it would make a lot
of sense for Joe borough to go and I
definitely want to see him at the Senior
Bowl so I am pretty biased here but I
hope that he does go it will be
interesting to see which four
quarterbacks hopefully fill out this
roster I'm sure that Jim naggy is doing
his due diligence though and they will
be four very good quarterbacks well the
other team will probably the Dolphins
yeah so probably Bengals dolphins both
need a quarterback so if you're Justin
Herbert I don't know why your name's not
on this roster yet no I'm gonna go with
this all those other guys have no room
to say no I mean Jalen Hertz you have to
go Justin Herbert I know he's going in
the top ten he needs to go I don't know
if Nate Stanley has an invite or not or
Jacob Eason but if they do two big arms
guys that are very raw and have some
question marks they need to go so I can
understand it for Joe Burrell why you're
waiting because that's a very long
season I do think he cemented himself as
the number one pick no matter what as
long as he stays out of trouble which I
am not concerned about that at all no
but those other guys they don't have
room to pass this opportunity up yeah I
think if you're burrowed that like the
argument to go is because you want to
control your you control your own
destiny if you go if you don't you do
have to worry about Herbert impressing
the Bengals or dolphins don't I'm
falling in love with him people looking
at the to a tape and saying you know
what we'll roll the dice on this hip
because he's incredibly accurate even
yeah with two I mean the injuries such a
question mark that if you go you can
cement your legacy and say okay I am QB
one it is risky everything's risky
at this part of the process if you're
that have a pick but I still think you
should be there I have a question for
you guys
if tua comes back from the combine and
medically gets the green light is he
your quarterback one for this draft no
too many injuries for me that's the only
reason I think two is the best pure
passer in the class me too I love this
leadership I love us football IQ two
ankles and a hip in two years
too much every year that's a lot there's
something going on that's limiting him
and we didn't talk about this lot
because - it got hurt midseason but it's
also a dude who is not known for being
like a weight room guy necessarily I'm
not trying to say anything negative
about to it but his conditionings not
been notable as great he's kind of a
soft body guy and now he's got three
injuries like that's enough for me to
have a concern there were a lot of
people worried about that injury and him
putting on weight after the injury after
this hit because he is very limited in
what he can do so after the injury if
they gave him a you know clean bill of
health
oh go back and probably dig a little bit
deeper into the quarterbacks but right
now I'm pretty solid with burrow one and
two a - yeah and then a gigantic chasm
yeah no don't worry about anyone else
right a lot of faith yeah we went off
the rails here so we'll clean up a
little bit of what's left with around
the league but Tom Coughlin's fired guy
73 years old out as VP of the
Jacksonville Jaguars when the NFL PA
puts out a statement that says you might
want to consider these illegal finds
that the Jags have been putting on
players if you were considering signing
with this club owner shad Kahn had to do
something fellows yeah you know I think
that he's gonna escape go here and
really you look at the Jags organization
they just paid a lot of money to a
quarterback that they're probably not
going to use going forward so there was
a lot of holes there and I think that
even if you look outside of the scandal
that's kind of going on they probably
needed some shake-up there in the front
office to get things going again yeah I
look at this and it makes you wonder if
this is just the first move this is that
immediate move but at the end of the
season are we just gonna get a clean
slate here in Jacksonville and
they wipe it clean they bring in a
player's coach a guy with a lot of
energy I think Robert salla would be
that kind of hire there's a lot of hires
that would be like that Matt rule would
be somebody like that
Robert salad would be somebody like that
the list really goes on and on where
they try to change the now reputation of
this franchise to bring in a lot of
players or keep the talented ones they
have they're happy and I actually like
Doug Marrone between my class if it's
all said I think Doug Marrone is a good
head coach yeah and I feel like Tom
Coughlin's was an unnecessary addition
to this team I know they got to the AFC
championship game but like Dave Caldwell
Doug Marrone we're doing okay I don't
know the Tom Coughlin really added
anything to this situation so if even if
they don't make a change I think they're
in decent shape
all right last big guys three players
have declared for the draft that are
notable here Kyle and Hill running back
from Mississippi State one over a
thousand yards this year Lynn Bowden the
do everything on offense player for
Kentucky receiver quarterback running
back and then cam Akers from Florida
State cam Akers had a nice bounce-back
year after a sophomore season that
definitely did not hit what we thought
it would I don't I don't see any of
these guys as first rounders I think I
would say Bowden is the one I'm most
intrigued by I think Kyle inand camera
day three running backs I would agree
with you I'm excited to see Lynn Bowden
a little bit more just because he played
so much damn quarterback this year which
is great his team needed him he stepped
up he played a different position but
man I really want to see what he could
do at receiver because he looked like a
special receiver Connor you've been
talking about this guy for a while now
it kind of sucks it's kind of cool that
he played so much quarterback but I
really want to see what he can do full
time at receiver hopefully we get a good
look at him at the combine without a
doubt I mean he was probably the best
returner in the country coming into this
season that could also play a slot
receiver and outside receiver and a
gadget guy on sweeps he comes into the
year it's a really really hot start at
the wide receiver position they lose
everything they have at quarterback and
he was also on special teams playing
really well and he has to move to
quarterback and when you do that you're
no longer on specials you're no longer a
wide receiver you're running the offense
it was a pretty impressive year for
Kentucky all things considered
thanks to Bowden being that unselfish I
think the things that stand out to me is
he has such good vision he's really fast
and it's like a deceptive fast where
it's build up speed when he got to the
second level of the field as a
quarterback he would hit you know hit
the gas and go for six really often he
breaks a lot of tackles and the few
things I saw a wide receiver at times
his hands were a little shaky but he can
make plays and he really can he's a
really good player and I had an
interesting question a couple of weeks
ago on Twitter somebody said hey is he
more Randall Cobb or is he more Braxton
Miller and I said this guy is not
Braxton Miller this guy can truly truly
play wide receiver yeah I think he's
didn't you're gonna go more Randall Cobb
definitely over those Braxton was like a
gadget guy playing that H position
getting moved to receiver so trying to
learn receiver Lynn Bowden was trying to
learn quarterback and going back all
right no blind review this week no blind
review for the rest of the year actually
Thursday night games are over Saturday
schedule looks great mellow and I'll be
breaking that down on the Monday morning
show take a break we come back we'll
hand out our college football hardware
for the year
last week the college football awards
show happened
and basically they announced on Twitter
and then ESPN did a show and gave out
all these awards to people so we're
gonna piggyback off that as long as I
can talk to the next three segments Mel
O'Connor might be doing most of this but
we decided to each give out our wards in
the major categories Heisman
yada-yada-yada citizens you know yeah I
think most of them are pretty obvious
but we don't agree on much so we can
kind of get a stick to football
two-thirds vote style of who we have
let's start it with the Heisman Trophy
obviously Joe Burrell won the award but
I'm going to disagree with the voters
because they [ __ ] this thing up
big-time
they put chase young for which I know
everybody's probably tired of talking
about but he would have been my number
one foe he would have been first place
for me if I had a Heisman vote yeah me
too mellow I think when I look at the
definition of the ward it's the most
outstanding player in the country and I
love what Joe Borough did he's been
awesome
chase Young was the best football player
in the country I
he did the most that his position and I
think he was unbelievable in every
aspect and you have to wonder if he
didn't miss two games would he have you
know generational numbers that gave him
a better chance than fourth place so for
me on the show you know we are very
biased with the hashtag defense for
Heisman and I believe it should have
went to chase young I actually I'm gonna
say it should have gone to Jill burrow
and it did you use because I I've said
this before and I'm not mister you know
stick to the rules but he was suspended
two games and I think that should make
you invalid for the Heisman Trophy I
don't think it should I mean like you
can't make the Pro Bowl if you were
suspended for a game I don't think you
should build one the Heisman if you're
suspended [ __ ] reason that's just my
purse like if I had a vote I would not
have voted chase Young first I would
have voted him second I don't think he
should be able to win the most iconic
award in sports after being suspended
for whether it's a rule you agree with
they're not he broke a rule and had to
be suspended for it yeah I it doesn't
matter to me though I don't care I go
back to Connors argument who was the
most dominating Oh what's a player in
college football it was chasing up
because up until he got suspended he
would have won the award so he still
gets my vote he gets the two-thirds
votes so congratulations to change young
you are the 2019 stick to football
Heisman Trophy winner
I had the joke walcker word this goes to
the best running back in the nation I
have to go to Chuba Hubbard way he did
at Oklahoma State this year I know they
weren't good but he was amazing this
year and when you I've said before you
put yourself in a category with Thurman
Thomas and Barry Sanders at that
University what over 1,900 rushing yards
this year on an offense that had nothing
else I know Jonathan Taylor was great
I know JK Dobbins was great Shuba
Hubbard was the man for me this year
yeah I'm gonna agree with you I'm going
with Juba as well but there are two
right answers here and I could go either
way to beau Hubbard or Jonathan Taylor
Jonathan Taylor was exceptional he
proved this year that he could catch the
ball out of the backfield as well I just
think that Chuba Hubbard was vastly
underrated and what he meant to this
offense he put up huge numbers was
except
you know all year his team isn't in a
lot of games without him in Jonathan
Taylor you can say the same at Wisconsin
I'm not hating on him if you're making
me vote for one of them though I'm going
with Juba Hubbard this was definitely
the toughest one and it was really a
three-man race for me between Shuba
Hubbard Jonathan Taylor and JK Dobbins I
went with Taylor because I think the
numbers were pretty close to Hubbard and
I just think it's harder to run in that
conference in the Big Ten I think you go
back to that Big Ten championship game
where he ran for almost 150 yards
against Ohio State and like you said
Melo he really showed the world that he
could also catch the ball this year so I
love what Shuba Hubbard has done and I'm
the loser here because it's already a
2/3 vote but I think for me it would go
to Jonathan Taylor because I think it
was a little harder for him to earn
those yards we got to bring that back
for just random tailgate tour 2020 we
just vote on everything all right the
blitek off goes to the best receiver in
the country I thought until about week
10 that this would be C D lamb but when
you look at what Jamar chase did at LSU
this is where my vote goes almost he had
1,400 98 yards the most of anyone a
college football eighth team touchdown
receptions on 73 catches that year
statistically was just too dominant for
me I thought like the eyeball test yes
it was C D lamb had he not had the hit
injury maybe he wins this award but just
couldn't quite get there for me in terms
of the numbers yeah I think again two
guys see D lamb I think it was the most
dangerous receiver in college football
this year but who had the best season
I'm gonna go with Jamar chase if C D
lamb doesn't miss a couple games if he
has maybe a better quarterback throwing
him the ball I mean he I mean Jalen Hurd
so I like him but he's not Joe burrow
throwing the football so that's the
difference maker here probably the
injuries the quarterback play CD lamb is
getting wide receiver one consideration
from me I can't believe how good he's
been this year after the catch to be not
a very fast guy not a track speed type
guy and to get away from defenders the
way he does is exceptional but I am
going with Jamar chase you throw up the
numbers that you mentioned Matt the 18
touchdowns that he had this year doing
it against SEC
he's gonna get my vote for the political
this was a fun year for wide receivers
in college football and and I'm with you
there Melo I think CD lamb is the best
wide receiver in this draft class right
now I think it's very close with him and
Judy but I love what I've seen from CD
and actually picked him for the blinkin
off here because I think he it was
harder for him because I don't think
Jalen Hertz is even on the same planet
as Joe burrow and Jamar chase he's
phenomenal and I'm so excited we get to
see him again in college football next
year but I think what CD it goes back to
a lot of people are gonna watch Jalen
Hertz and they're gonna go wow it's a
good thing he has CD lamb because some
of these throws are seven to eight yard
throws that and zooty lamb breaking nine
tackles for 50 or 60 yard play over and
over again or CD lamb coming back to the
football or mossing someone so I thought
CD lamb was the best wide receiver in
the country this year I also thought it
was ridiculously close and I think for
Jamar chase there's been some huge
moments on some big games because let's
be real LSU has just played in more big
games this year than Oklahoma and I
would have put Devon to Smith third by
the way I agree which I think surprised
a lot of people but that five touchdown
game against Ole Miss by itself has to
put you in the conversation to have the
year that he had was very impressive
alright the Mackay award goes to the
best tight end I actually thought we all
three had the same guy then I realize I
type my name in wrong oh I have a
Harrison Brian I know I like the other
guy but Harrison Bryant is where I went
over a thousand yards too tight in seven
touchdowns we're gonna see him at the
Senior Bowl I think everyone will really
like his game he is not in all-around
tight end necessarily but what he does
up the seam as a receiving target is
really exciting and again the year he
had I remember talking to Dana Holgorsen
about this with you guys last year when
you have a tight in catch 65 passes in
college football that's an insane seven
touchdowns it's really really good so
Harrison Bryant gets my vote yeah I
typed in the wrong names so I lose again
there's actually hurts it was across the
board I was like
tied in we all agree move on nope we
don't I'm going Harrison Bryant as well
playing at FAU obviously that conference
is very tough but he did have an
exceptional year like you said Matt
going for over a thousand yards even
when you look at a guy like Bryson
Hopkins who I think is another really
good tight end that we'll get to see
both of these guys at the Senior Bowl is
gonna be awesome
I don't know that they're no a fan or TJ
Hawkinson like we had last year but to
see them battle it out with each other
at the Senior Bowl is gonna be great and
there's some other good tine Institute
right Connor yeah there is I picked
hunter Brian it's not Harrison Bryant to
win this award
I think Harrison Bryant had a phenomenal
year and had great numbers and I think
hunter Bryant did the same in the pac-12
he was really a go-to target for Jacob
Eason I think a lot of people are gonna
go back and look at Jacob Eason film and
go man that guy number 1 is the best
athlete on the field very very often so
I love his ability as a move tight end
he's 62 240 compared him to Evan Engram
over 800 yards as a tight end this year
in college football that's super super
impressive so if your last name is Brian
on 6 to football you take home the
Mackay award the Wright brothers they're
actually not related the åland award
this one is tough because it can be an
offensive or defensive lineman it has to
in my opinion it has to be penny I don't
know he says name his a google penny
penny Sewell left tackle Oregon man did
give up a sack all year he actually
hasn't given one up in college two years
starting on the left side he's going to
be a top five pick next year he might be
the number one pick next year he's that
good
I think watch Oregon play watch watch
what Justin hard work is able to do
there's a reason he's so confident in
the pocket we talked about it preseason
Oregon might have the best offensive
line of football LSU will in the Joe
Moore award Oregon was right there with
them though and penny is the man yeah I
agree with you and this how crazy I am
I've already started a 2021 big board
and he's sitting on top of it right now
Trevor Lawrence Justin fields will
probably get drafted number one overall
but I think that 2 to 3 spot is gonna be
school he's just so good to be that big
and to be able to move like he
can we haven't seen it at tackle we
wanted it to happen with Andrew Thomas
it just really didn't so I'm really
hoping we get it with Sewell next year
I'm he's a sophomore this year he can't
come out but next year with him I I
really am excited about what he can do
whatever quarterback he's protecting
he's gonna have some good running backs
very excited to see what he can do he's
gonna win the award for me best lineman
offensive or defensive man I don't agree
with you guys on anything right now I
went with Derrick brown for this that's
good yeah I thought he had a Quinn in
Williams type of year and Quintin
Williams won this last year I think when
you look at Sewell he's amazing and he
should win this next year but I think
Derrick brown going back for his senior
year
oddly enough with these trophies that
gets factored in at times obviously
Brown was a completely dominant player
he really was and I think if Albarn had
snuck out a couple of those wins they
could have had against teams that are in
the playoff along those lines
you know like in LSU I think we'd hear
more about Brown in the national picture
for college football but unfortunately
that's not the case this was a tough one
to pick again because there are so many
good players but I just love what
Derrick Brown did this year where do you
guys have Brown ranked I have him six
overall that's a great question I think
I've I've okay yeah I don't think he's
getting enough love he's not man he's
like Nick Fairley was dominated for a
while yes I actually think Derrick brown
can stay in the league was weight under
control so yeah in dominance ooh but to
be as big as he is 6 5 3 18 just moves
well I really think that he's gonna
dominate in the NFL if I were giving
this award to a defensive lineman
interior-wise I mean he's special he's
one of the best that I've seen yeah I
compared him to Chris Jones so I like
that pretty excited we'll see how he
does in the 40 yeah if anyone can top
chris balls to the walls
the been eric and the Nagurski awards
this goes to the Defensive Player of the
Year
this is unanimous we are all giving them
to chase young take your two trophies
young man I didn't give you the Heisman
but I will give you these yeah
I think this one's a no-brainer you look
at the best defensive player obviously
he's the Heisman Trophy winner for stick
to football here so he has to be the
best defensive player is well contested
I mean this is the easiest one there's
nothing else left to say this is chase
Young's award all right let's move on
then to the Butkus to the best
linebacker in the country I think this
one is tough because you can look at
someone like Kenneth Murray who
definitely had the production you look
at isaiah simmons who had the pedigree
has the spotlight there's some other
players Connors gonna highlight one
because Melo and I agree it's Isaiah
Simmons I may be cheated here because I
went with the best linebacker prospect
who just happened to be the best
linebacker player this year Micah
Parsons would be really really close for
me and it's a shame Dylan Moses got hurt
because I think this was his award to
win yeah go ahead no I would go with
like Kenneth Murray is a good pick
Connor you the guy you have on here is
Evan Weaver do you look at just tackle
numbers and what you put up it is
ridiculous I mean I looked at it because
I I made my first team all Americans you
compare what Evan Weaver is done Luke
Kuechly is like the only linebacker that
has more tackles than him and oh yeah
what Luke Kuechly did at Boston College
is [ __ ] ridiculous he was getting
like 190 tackles a year Evan Weaver
comes in this year 172 I mean it's not
so he's definitely up there as a guy you
want to look at production nobody's been
more productive and we'll see him at the
Senior Bowl nobody's been more
disruptive though than Isiah Simmons I
love what he can do obviously I'm very
high on him I've been talking about him
all year he's my number four player
overall right now some team is gonna be
very lucky to get him on that defense I
don't know where he's gonna play I don't
know how they're gonna do it but he'll
be all over the field that's why I'm
gonna give him this award for best
linebacker Simmons versatility is really
unbelievable but just classic college
linebacker I had to give this award to
Evan Weaver
like you said 172 tackles this year
coming off a 20-18 with 155 tackles he
was the heart and soul of that Cal
defense and you know they had their ups
and downs this year they really did but
that defense had a lot of games where
they carried an offense that just could
not move the ball and Weaver whether
it's his in
is leadership how great and consistent
of a tackler he was the guy was amazing
this year he really was and I thought he
was the best I don't think will be the
best linebacker in the draft at all but
I thought he was the best linebacker in
college football this year yeah I loved
watching him play this year all right
boys the Thorpe Award this is one that I
actually had a big problem with who won
this they gave it to Grant Delpit and I
tweeted about it how I was unhappy and
some of the voters actually reached out
to me and said hey you know just saw
your tweets and wanted to explain this
award is not just about production but
it's about leadership and character and
the person okay if you want to throw
that criteria in there great double
probably should be on the list but he
was not good this year
so I actually still take issue because
there are other good leaders out there
that you could give this to I would have
given it given it to Derek Stingley jr.
especially we're just basing it on what
a guy did on the field as a true
freshman to have six interceptions and
15 passes defensed this year that is
incredible but there's a long list of
guys you could have given this to his
teammate Christian Bolton who battled
through an ankle injury and was a leader
for them you could have given it to
Antoine Winfield junior could have given
it to Jeff Okuda could have given it to
Sean Wade for all I care
it feels like there were so many guys
that grant Delpit just won this because
of name recognition yeah it is it feels
like that definitely that they said okay
who was supposed to win this award did
he do okay does he have high character
sure and then they voted for him my pick
is gonna be Antoine Winfield junior the
small an undersized safety out of
Minnesota obviously his dad played in
the NFL for a while I think he had an
exceptional year you look at his numbers
it's not just about production but
making a difference in the game making
big plays when he needs 283 tackles for
him coming from the safety position
three sacks this year being a guy who's
510 they list him at 200 pounds
he's probably five nine 185 to make that
kind of impact against the run and
rushing the quarterback oh by the way
seven interceptions up there one of the
tops in the entire nation I think he's
getting overlooked because it's
Minnesota he's undersized he's not the
big name
yet if we see this guy come back next
year I think that he's gonna be a
favorite for the award but absolutely
dominated college football this year he
just doesn't have that big name he's not
a big prospect like a grant Delpit so
he's my pick game against Fresno State
is one of the best any safety hat all
year yeah I mean watch Minnesota play I
know that we have some fans that are
listeners that are Minnesota fans he
really makes a difference if its third
and ten
he's ball Hawking he's somewhere around
the ball he's blitzing off that nickel
corner spot I think that he's gonna be a
very valuable safety corner guy much
like we're seeing with a guy like
quandary dick so that that's who I look
at and say he's an undersized safety he
kind of plays some corner he doesn't
have that true position but he's gonna
make a difference
in a football game this has become an
award based on hype it really has that's
why Grant Delpit got this award and I
feel like I was one of the leaders of
the grants out but hype coming into this
year I wouldn't even have him as a
finalist for this award
yeah that's the thing I didn't even
think he was good enough to be a
finalist here and it goes to show you
how many guys were better than him all
three of us picked someone else and all
three of them were better options than
him I went with Jeff Okuda I think Jeff
Okuda would have never had the numbers
for this award because why would you
ever throw the football in his direction
he had three interceptions and seven
passes defensed let's be real the guy is
the best corner prospect in this class
and he is lights out on his side of the
football field he really really is and I
thought what I saw on film of Jeff Okuda
was significantly more impactful than
anything grant Delpit did in any single
game this year so I like all of our
choices there's no two-thirds vote for
this one or three out of three vote
because these guys were all just great
options
they are great options let us know who
you guys think should have won these
awards where we got it wrong tweet us at
stick to football we'll be back with our
top five what ifs right after this
I don't you guys saw on Twitter this
week but there was a great question post
and it was the what is your greatest
sports what if we thought this week we
would take that expand it a little bit
and give you our top five what if if you
guys don't mind why the voice while the
voice is holding up I'm gonna go ahead
my top five hopefully it'll work here
number five guys what if Brady's Tuck
game was ruled a fumble the Raiders go
to the Super Bowl
the Patriots dynasty maybe never get
started Adam Vinatieri is not the
greatest kicker of all time
the last 20 years of football completely
probably bring drew bledsoe back maybe
no Tom Brady the Jets are in the Super
Bowl every year so there you go so
that's a that's a huge one where you can
like you can change 20 years of NFL
history on that one play so what if
Brady what if it's ruled a fumble number
two and this is a big one as a Niners
fan because I grew up in this era where
it was Joe Montana was hurt all the time
Steve Young would come in they would
play great and then Steve Young would go
back to the bench
I'm just sit back while the 49ers fans
try to kill you through your what if
Steve Young was given the job in like 91
when Montana got hurt when he hurt his
back
I think the Niners would have a couple
more Super Bowl wins 90-93 that was a
great team they should have won it that
year I think the 92 team probably should
have won it but Montana's injuries held
this team back
I think the Niners have two more Super
Bowls if they had binge to Montana for
Steve Young at the end of his career
that's a bold take but all right you
guys have fun on Twitter with that one
number three what if the Oakland Raiders
hired Bill Belichick over Jon Gruden
and that might sound really [ __ ]
random but Amy trask who was the team
president lobbied for this she wanted Al
Davis to hire Bill Belichick over Jon
Gruden and I wouldn't do it how
different is the work Cleveland it was
when he got fired from Cleveland way to
go Brown how different is the world if
the Raiders hire Bill Belichick instead
number two what if Michael Jordan
doesn't wink-wink nudge-nudge retire oh
you're gonna share that conspiracy
theory that's a well known conspiracy
theory that he was suspended by the NBA
for gambling that he didn't actually
higher I'm into that I believe it they
want five conspiracy theories will
happen on the show soon enough we're
just scared to touch it I think they
would win two more NBA championship
exactly so there would have been no but
what does that do this Spurs
you know the legacy there no there's
they're fine the Spurs came afterwards
like guys like Hakeem Olajuwon never was
an Indian ship Yeah right yeah I mean
you look at so many players that were
blocked by Michael Jordan Carmelo John
Stockton like nobody from that era has
an NBA championship right team Elijah
won because they all got blocked by
joint is like you know what [ __ ] it we
can't win let's put up banners because
we won the Western Conference right and
my number one and this one's so close to
me what if Joe Kane doesn't get a DUI on
that motorcycle after the bar fight in
the program an es you would probably
ones national championship no you got
wins the Heisman John wins Heisman
Trophy enters the draft is the fictional
number one no one's talking about Tim
women no way no no one cares Darnell
Jefferson probably rushes for 800 yards
like three people will read it but
before I die I will write a sequel to
the program as a book that would be
amazing
I don't think three people would read I
think there's a unique audience out
there that would jump all over it I know
Andrew Magnuson would I might do that
this summer just for shits and giggles I
might write the sequel to the program
yeah I hope you cast it at least all
right all right I'll read through mine
I'm gonna start at number one this one's
near and dear to me I want to know what
if Vince Young was drafted to a
different team or playing in this era of
football right now one of the most
special athletes you look at obviously
Lamar Jackson you look at Michael Vick
Vince Young is right there in that
category for most athletic quarterbacks
I've ever seen he just was in a very
shitty situation he brought a lot of it
on himself I mean the guys still getting
in a little bit of trouble but to have
him playing in an offense like what
Colin Kaepernick was playing or what
we're seeing with Lamar Jackson if he
got drafted to a difference
I think that he's still in the league
he's probably still running all over the
field
it could be exceptional I'm multiple if
he Norm Chow hadn't tried to make him a
pocket passer he was he was the Rookie
of the Year he came in led the Titans to
multiple victories I think that he could
have if he could have landed in a
different situation we talked about
situation and how important it is he
landed in a shitty one with the Titans
so what if Vince Young were dropped into
a different team number two
what if Brett Favre never retired I mean
I'm talking from the Packers I know
there are a couple ones there were so
many but what if this guy stays in Green
Bay
I Aaron Rodgers probably gets pissed off
and has to move on he's probably at a
new team now the Packers don't have that
transition from one MVP to another I
would like to see what he could have
done the records that he could have set
if he stayed with the Packers and had
that just that feel of the offense and
being comfortable there
he didn't we'll never know number three
for me gotta stick with the Longhorns
here if Colt McCoy doesn't get hurt they
win the national championship
I don't even know if that's a what if
that's just that should be a fact out
there if he doesn't get hurt I want to
see what kind of Pro this guy's gonna be
because he's still kicking it around in
the league he's barely got a shoulder
attached to his body
thanks to Marcel Darius what if Colt
McCoy doesn't get hurt maybe he gets
drafted a little bit higher I'm very
biased towards Colt McCoy there's a lot
of Longhorns who I'm not tied to it's
Colt McCoy it's Pune Ford that's pretty
much it I want to see what happens if
Colt McCoy stays healthy if he still has
a shoulder the next two let's dig way
back what happens if Bo Jackson never
gets hurt I think that's one that a lot
of people consider and talk about I
think he could have been one of the
greatest running backs of all time he
put Marcus Allen out of a job I did
benefit from him getting hurt because he
was a Kansas City royal and a great
all-star outfielder but playing with him
on Tecmo Bowl and I was a little bit too
young to see him play in the NFL for
very long but if he were to stay healthy
with that hip obviously he could have
been very special at running back and
I'll stick with the baseball team Ken
Griffey Jew
just don't leave Seattle never gets hurt
I think we're talking about the best
baseball player of all time if he
doesn't do that the Gold Gloves being
able to run the bases the home runs the
swing everything it would've been
Michael Jordan but with baseball I he
would have been the best of all time in
my opinion yeah that's one of my
favorite ones cuz you always got to ask
yourself like what would have Griffey
been like in the non-steroid era oh my
god it's almost like he is greatness
gets buried because of you he was in
that era the guy went healthy was one of
the greatest athletes we've ever seen
that's one of the only times I've met an
athlete that came into bleacher report
and I was like starstruck because we
interview and when you meet ken griffey
jr. it's like holy [ __ ] like every white
kid in America wear their baseball hat
backward because of ken griffey jr.
totally he changed the culture of the
game yeah I mean even after he got hurt
he was still hitting like 20 30 home
runs a year while injured I mean if he
could have just stayed healthy he's
hitting you know 45 plus home runs
probably every hit 56 when you're right
I think so yeah
twice so what a Barry Bonds and never
taking steroids then he would probably
still hit 600 home runs be in the Hall
if he would still be alive he would be
in the great baseball player I saw
nobody Adam Heisler tweet about that
nobody knows hitters like that guy
number five for me is a little bit of
story time what if the Jets never got
Brett Favre and this one is so fun
because obviously it's personal but
story time aspect is Eric Mangini
did not want Brett Favre they were going
into camp with Chad Pennington that year
and man Jeannie was like Penningtons my
guy and the owner of course Woody
Johnson was like we're getting Brett
Favre you have no choice move on from
Chad Pennington well that year while the
Jets did star 8 & 3 with Favre and then
he hurt his shoulder and everything went
to [ __ ] they didn't make the playoffs
Chad Pennington led the Dolphins to an
AFC East title that is the last time
somebody but the New England Patriots
won the AFC East in 2008 so it really
really makes you wonder number four for
me is what if Tom Brady went one pick
later instead of 199 he went 200 to the
Saints
can you imagine the trickle effect of
that if he lasted one more pick no drew
Brees greatness in New Orleans
who knows what would have happened how
good would Brady have been in New
Orleans the draft ones for this are
ridiculous I'm gonna go right to another
one what if Andrew Luck retired just a
little bit earlier
the Colts never trade the third overall
pick to the Jets and they take Wow a
quarterback of the future say the Colts
take Sam darn 'old at three instead and
the Jets take Josh Allen Josh Rosen
whoever it may be the entire dynamic of
the future quarterback in the league
would be so so difficult to go Marv
Jackson that would be wild and really
fun but guess what didn't work out that
way number two what if David Wright
never got hurt David Wright was a
seven-time all-star in two-time gold
Glover and in his early 30s 31 years old
he gets spinal stenosis completely ruins
his career you know one of he could have
been one of the best third baseman of
all time considering how long guys play
that position into their 30s late 30s
that injury was crushing one more draft
one here that would have changed the
last 15 years of the NFL what if Eli
Manning didn't protest going to the
Chargers what if he just sucked it up
and said I'll be a charger and what
because that trade was the Giants took
Phillip Rivers traded them what if
Phillip Rivers was in New York giant so
they win those Super Bowls do they win
more Super Bowls do the Chargers win
Super Bowls with Eli Manning and can you
imagine Phillip Rivers
a giant in New York yeah then the media
would just be crazy with him I lasted I
think he would have he would have got
out and moved on I agree it was best for
both but it makes you wonder like people
don't talk about that Eli Manning came
out and said I won't play for the team
pick and then they drafted him do you
guys you know what [ __ ] you we got you
buddy and that trade actually led to not
only the Chargers getting Philip Rivers
but one of the other picks they acquired
in that trade was for Shawne Merriman
mmm-hmm that's huge the extra
first-rounder mattered and the Chargers
had Drew Brees LaDainian Tomlinson at
the same time and they didn't keep
either of them and a guy named Antonio
Gates good here's a trivia do you guys
know who was
pick right before Tom Brady Matt Bowen
matt bone yes money for that I don't
know is that Chargers team that didn't
make a Superbowl the greatest team to
not make one would the team that when
what year was it didn't they win 14
games I'm looking it up right now
I believe they finished first dollar
team in defense yeah Oh 14 and 2 yeah 14
and 2 and 2006 they lost the divisional
round that was their first year with uh
with the rivers yes yeah like LT was
just running over everyone
catching lt1 the MVP that year yeah
Marty Schottenheimer leave me and they
fired my coach Marty was fired after a
14 win season
Lorenzo Neal was on how do you get after
a 14 that keenum a card L - I think a
good team Vincent Jackson all right
let's take a break when we come back
your draft on Drive questions instead of
us just going down memory lane yeah in
the NFL Draft on draft time this first
one from Tyler Reynolds how and why has
the perception from national media
changed so rapidly on Ohio State from
weeks ago to the playoff we were talking
about how great this team can beats now
all of a sudden they're gonna be dog
walked by Clemson again I think the
perception hasn't changed on Ohio State
I think the perception has changed on
Clemson where people are saying you know
you better look out for these guys I
know them playing anybody in the ACC so
there's so much talent on that team they
were the number one team coming into
this year for a reason and they're
starting to get their [ __ ] together and
that's scary for people it's not that oh
hi oh state has regressed at all it's
that people are finally opening their
eyes to Clemson Ohio State's still great
I think that they made an argument for
being the number one team but now you're
number two and you have to face the
defending national champions who brought
back their quarterback there are two
receivers they're running back offensive
linemen and their defense looks
unstoppable again so I think it's more
to do with Clemson looking great than
Ohio State looking bad I agree with
everything you just said I
love Tyler this is my pet peeve though
is when people asked because I get asked
us all time like why are you different
than the national media on a player or a
team I don't know because I don't talk
to the national media like we don't have
a convention where we sit around and
like debate about why we're tell you
know you know I don't go to the
convention I'm not invited up so I will
say like that's a weird pet peeve of
mine because I get asked it daily why
are you different about X Y & Z than the
rest of the media I don't [ __ ] know
cuz they haven't explained to me why
like why they think the way they do I
will say that with Ohio State just like
you said though clemson has been there
and done it and Ryan Day is still first
your head coach and I think there's
always gonna be a little bit of
skepticism when it comes to a first-year
head coach a first year quarterback
against a team that did it last year
yeah I mean listen I'm with you all the
way there I think the weird thing about
this conversation is and I fell victim
to this because we got busy we were on
the road
non-stop this year that slow start by
Trevor Lawrence it took me a couple
weeks of him being great to be like oh
[ __ ] like he looks amazing again we just
didn't get to catch up on all of it that
fast and now you watch it you go that
offense is pretty much the same team
that won a national title blew the doors
off Alabama last year and I'm that
better Alabama not only were we on the
road they weren't playing anyone so by
the time it was like oh [ __ ] they're
back to where they were last year it was
like okay they beat Charlotte you know
it's like oh they're scoring a ton of
points again they barely beat North
Carolina I think into September and I
were I mean that's when I was like okay
who the [ __ ] is this team but then they
just started stopping people again so
it's a mixture being busy and then also
like they didn't play anyone see all you
know now let's go Paul Finebaum on you
guys but they really didn't play anyone
yeah and they're peaking at the right
time which makes them super scary
alright next question from al I love a
simple name like that in the rundown all
sorts of mock drafts have the bills
taking a receiver in the first round
we're guilty of that on here
how much does or should it matter that
bills offensive coordinator Brian De Vil
coached the three Bama receivers as
freshmen when he was bamas offensive
coordinator of course Judy won't be on
the board for them
but would that make to Vaughn to Smith
or Henry rugs a better fit than lamb or
Chenal I mean you always yeah the double
you know it's always better than one you
don't but like like al says here I don't
even think rugs is gonna be there for
the bills where they're at right now I
mean not 25 they keep winning and I
think Devon to Smith we've heard he
might go back to school I I think that
you can always note commonalities like
this or connections like this but I'll
never forget people saying Doug Marrone
was gonna draft Ryan nasty Ben Buffalo
because he had coached him a Syracuse he
did not draft him in Buffalo and so
sometimes because you've coached guys
you don't want them those are wisest in
with these Alabama receivers they're all
small guys and what we've been talking
about with the bills is give Josh Allen
a big target he's got a guy in John
Brown that can go deep he's got cold
Beasley that can hit that short
intermediate stuff give him T Hagan give
him a big target like a t Higgins or
even I like Shayne alt could be that
give him a big target a red zone weapon
that he can really go and utilize I
think they've already got two pretty
good receivers in place so I even if you
have Devon to Smith sitting there I
don't know if they'd take the chance on
that him playing in that division in the
cold weather I I think they're gonna go
with more of a T Higgins type guy a
Michael Pittman maybe in the end of the
first round we'll see how far they go
where they're picking right now at 25
you're not getting Judy you're probably
not getting rugs either know and I think
Donovan people's Jones is another
interesting one for them oh that's
that's the conversation that they're in
right now all right Thomas Burton for us
giraffe process and newbies what are the
rules for player conduct in regards to
getting banned from the senior bowl or
combine would say Class B misdemeanor
possession possession charge be the end
of the world for a certain Utah State
quarterback yeah so the way it works now
it is a little ambiguous and some agents
have fought against it but it's
basically if you have an assault charge
you can be banned from the combine you
know we've seen it with guys like Joe
Mixon and others but a Class B
misdemeanor nope nobody cares yeah NFL's
not gonna care he'll be at the combine
still gonna be a senior role know if he
fails to test the combine we'll talk
then it's an issue yeah cuz you know
that was coming
yeah and for the combines
stuff you know we're usually out in
front you'll get tipped off of guys that
you know aren't eligible because of
certain incidents
I believe that happened to Preston
Williams last year
yep correct yeah so it happens
especially anything domestic related but
yeah it can be a little bit of a gray
area it really can all right James de
moose if you were to do the NFL top 100
and select the top players by team
rather than the whole NFL which team
would have the best roster if we're
going all time I should say is a tall
timer now well the NFL 100 some time so
I would say the Pittsburgh Steelers
I mean their whole team from the 70s
pretty much made it you look at some of
those linebackers in the 90s and 2000's
I there's gonna be a lot of players in
that that list yeah
Steelers 9 how boys it's the Niners -
you would have Joe Montana Jerry Rice
Randy Moss was a Niner for a second you
could throw him on I know the old line
would be weak but the Noorani lot you'd
have ronnie Lott you have three pearls
Haley you do you get Charles who the
Cowboys
oh no I thought you were saying the if
you could accumulate the best like who
would have the best all-time roster
basically I'm sorry I misunderstood but
oh I did the same thing as Matt maybe
we're all just idiots sorry James we
tried to answer your question and give
you even then I still think the Steelers
I think their weakest position is
probably quarterback right in the
Cowboys I mean really the Cowboys are
gonna be tough to be they're gonna have
the best shutdown corner of all time
they have the leading rusher in the NFL
with Emmitt Smith that offensive line
that's insane
they're gonna be too deep at offensive
line that's just gonna be yeah nasty Jay
Novacek Daryl Johnston yeah Cowboys
should be pretty pretty tough to beat
did I say Dion Dion is gonna be on there
for the Cowboys probably week at free
safety doesn't matter you have dionan
right there wasn't
alright last question of draft on draft
for today and if you've sent one to us
whether it's via DM and we've answered
you or we haven't we're still getting
those in so listen next week and we'll
still use all your questions because
we've gotten a lot of good ones lately
but this one from our buddy bar oopah
how closely do you all follow National
Signing Day any recruits you predict on
your big board three to four years from
now I give it a little bit of attention
I'm definitely not putting people like
on a big board I talked to you earlier
bear I have a 2021 big board that's
really just like players trying to get
out in front of it right a lot of these
guys I don't know him I know that the
big Clemson reach the quarterback he
sounds special I know a lot of Alabama
fans are very excited about Bryson young
other than that no I look at some of
these Texas guys where they're gonna
land what people like Adam Kramer saying
about him other than that I want to see
who's gonna make an impact as a freshman
when they start to become a freshman and
they're actually playing against college
level guys then I'm gonna start watching
them Brian Bri see is the number one
recruit going to Clemson he's a big
defensive tackle I've never watched a
single second of him play football I
will say that as a Texas fan I've been
burned by recruiting rankings so many
times where sure you know when when
Texas I'm Malik Jefferson tagada those
kids out of Florida it was like this is
gonna be the turning point
oh and no it wasn't none of them ended
up good and so it's just I mean it's fun
and it's like this is probably what
being a fan of the draft is like cuz you
just sold hopes and dreams but investing
in 17 18 year old kids to be the future
is really really tough and you and I
will say the guys who do recruiting
rankings god bless you cuz our job is
hard your job is harder to predict how
good a 17 or 16 year old that's gonna be
so I don't pay attention outside of you
know we have our friends so the
University of Texas they tell us who
they're excited about and I might watch
some huddle clips every now and then but
that's about as close as I get it's such
crap yeah shoot it is it is I'm not in
it like I used to be when I started
Bleacher Report I was a lot more
involved because we did so many
different video series with recruits
well there was army all-american or
recruiting videos so we're commitment
videos now the extent of it for me is
the great push notifications from the
Bleacher Report app that says this five
star player went here and then if it
intrigues me I open it up read a little
bit about them and go okay let's see how
he gets through his first spring or
something like that I mean that's what
it comes down to his first camp so I'm
with you guys that if you get so caught
up in the hype of recruiting classes
there's so many times where some guys
don't even ever play exactly I'm going
through and looking at old lists and
like don't know him
I watched a lot of college football I
should know you if you're the number
five recruit in the nation go through
the top 25 s of the lasts like 10 years
and there is a handful in every list
that you would never even know appeared
on it put a uniform on and it's not like
oh this guy signed it UT Tech or you
know somewhere like that that there's
guys going to Alabama State Florida
State then you never hit the field and
don't do anything but they're 5-star
recruits so yeah I'll pay a little bit
of attention I paid a lot of attention
last year because I was really excited
about
kayvon Thibodeau and what he was able to
do a lot of people were talking about
him it's like I couldn't get away from
him so I was like you know what I'm
gonna go ahead and watch some tape on
him but still watching these guys
dominate the high school level doesn't
put him on my draft radar I remember
when Jonathan gray came out and he had
set every Texas rushing record for the
state high school and the Longhorns were
very excited about him he didn't do [ __ ]
he didn't get drafted he was an okay
running back at Texas so I'm not gonna
let their ranking and how they're
recruited affect the draft if you go
back to 2016 the top five players were
rashon Gary
Dexter Lawrence Shay Patterson Jacob
Eason and Greg little those five names
we at least know yeah yeah at least know
but they're not top five in their draft
classes no Dirk Brown was number six edy
Oliver was seven how was he Nick Bose it
was ten folks so it's correct and I mean
guys like that age they're at that
they developed from 17 years old 16
years old to 21 is off the charts
I mean che never really got any better
no so it's it's wild it is such a crap I
mean it's funny it's like it's funny
hearing it from us cuz we do the draft
and everyone calls it a crapshoot
shoot no way no way I would ever want to
live in that world so props to everybody
that does all right that is our show
like said Monday morning mellow and I
will be giving you a show live from
somewhere on our way to Chicago or home
from Chicago where we'll be at bears
Chiefs this weekend
Connor gets a rare weekend off to enjoy
jet Steelers B and then Wednesday is
Christmas we do have a new show coming
out Wednesday morning it will be I'm
conducting interviews all week
Darrin Waller II know Benjamin will have
some good interviews for you guys new
stuff not old stuff next Christmas
morning and then Friday next week normal
show again no YouTube the next two weeks
but we will talk to y'all real soon